now God you see
is the show with all the words
[Music]
like And subscribe
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
we could just cancel the Sip you guys
can let us know in chat I don't know I
don't know how that became a thing
you got it
I don't like it I need to be free I need
to be free creatively I don't want to be
tied to the SIP uh glad you're with you
that's the sound of uh of Monday it's
our first day where we're not doing uh
free mug Club month anymore so you get
to watch the rest of the hour show of
course uh on uh well actually only on
Mud Club not necessarily on Rumble uh we
have a lot to get to today uh I don't
know if you know this but we're now
allowing illegal lgbtq AIP we're giving
them the right-of-way yeah they get the
Express checkout now as a matter of
policy that if they're 12 lesbians or
less or sometimes if there's 13 drag
queens that's what we call the grace
drag queen and uh we're exporting the
United States we're exporting uh lgbtq
AIP uh degeneracy I don't know if you
know this right now tried to send it out
to Japan and I said oh no no no no
perversion disgusting yes but that's
what we want to do uh so for the first
time in American history I would say
there are some things that uh still
proud to be American
um you know remember when Michelle Obama
said for the first time in her life when
her husband was proud to be uh she was
proud to be an American when her husband
became president yeah the reverse of
that for me for the first time in my
adult life there's some area I'm kind of
embarrassed I don't know if you guys can
comment below you feel that way I'm
patriotic for what America was what it's
been since its Inception up until today
and I don't know I'm not a big fan of
what it is that we're spreading across
the globe uh new credit rules for
everybody out there if you have low
credit you get actually better terms so
you're welcome and AOC wants us to
censor everybody who's not AOC Fox News
they call for censorship they call for
removal of Fox News and people to
disagree with and of course big Tech is
complicit go talk about a lot that and
more I don't know God you guys just
sandwiched in a lizzo thing I just saw
it's hard to sandwich that in Gerald hey
number two how are you sir I'm doing
well how are you I'm good yeah good I uh
I'm you know tired my son through a fit
because he had to get off the choo choo
at the mall and then it was a big it was
his first public fit are you not taking
him back to said Chuchu or I did I took
him twice ah I took him twice but I
can't afford it three times because I'm
a juju
well it's been claimed and you know him
you love him you hear this you know who
it is he is in
uh ocean at the Oceanfront Resort the
Hilton in Daytona Beach Florida also has
a roller skating party May 12th
and then May 19th and 20th at hyenas in
Dallas oh in Dallas Texas uh so go to
Nick dip or nickdepaloshow.com where you
can go and see all those tour dates yep
I say the funniest man alive on stage
Nick the Powell how are you sir very
good Michelle Obama said that was the
first time she's proud of the American
write-up she was drafted by the Cowboys
second round
I loved her dumping iron yeah they put
her under the nickel package
so you shouldn't even have good form she
didn't fully extend the tricep extension
see when I do it I do the full extension
Ah that's the pretty good arm for a TV
show host
oh you're far too flattering this would
never be allowed on TV
oh the real easy to use that term really
so it's but now it's just what people
watch no one watches TV anymore webisode
webisode it's horrendous yeah it's silly
what we do is silly speaking I'm just
trying to avoid this because we have to
watch this I'm sorry Nick Friday lizzo
brought drag queens on stage uh to her
Knoxville concert to protest Tennessee's
law I don't know if you know they're
bagging they're banning drag shows for
minors right which basically seems like
you know you're Banning miners from
going to strip clubs how dare they yeah
good so not to be out compounding the
issue adding yes yes giving it weight is
uh here's lizzo bringing drag queens on
the stage and let's just roll it because
there's no other way to I've been
putting this off long enough
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
no that was me
Nick was there yes
notice notice I don't know
Tom Jones concert unless a spiked jock
I uh uh I just uh um I I uh notice
there's not a lot of like 70 year old
lizos around so yes it's beautiful and
brave but you're dying yeah she she
looks again not to make another NFL
reference was uh please do Lyman call
Nate Newton yes yes that's what that was
that was the purple people eaters it's
just uh
unbelievable what is she deadlifting she
doesn't really need a deadlift so much
as like just she just puts hooks on her
hands and leans right away that takes
400 pounds off the bar it's a leverage
thing so you have to respect your
Technique and this is the thing this is
by the way before being overturned in
the Tennessee federal court the law
banned adult Cabaret entertainment where
miners might be attending so that's what
she's protesting is bringing out a bunch
of drag queens to her Showtime men
acting like women yeah is appropriate
for children and she feels that she
needs to protest and do you notice she
put all the fat ones right at the front
of the line yes are there any other kind
seriously oh look at the other drag
queens they did some push-ups thank God
you have a small monitor I have to see
[Music]
thank you
how dare you be intolerant and I think
the pendulum's swinging the other way
how many of you right now say you know
what intolerance and patience those
aren't uh weaknesses that I'm going to
I'm going to hold as a value anymore
yeah no and look when Taylor Swift goes
out and you know undulates in something
that's barely covering her body I'm like
look I don't want girls to see watch
this Taylor Swift isn't it I don't think
she does that she did that at her last
one
yes can I see footage yes no it's more
lit more lizzo for you don't finish your
lizzo Taylor Swift but that's the thing
she's not the worst of it that's not
somebody who we go oh yeah of course she
does that it's like somebody who doesn't
necessarily always do that and it's kind
of like
but I wouldn't like that for them anyway
so why is it something
[Music]
kids at strip clubs it's that simple by
the way I don't know if in case you're
wondering how important it is to lgbtqa
the gay event in in Florida I think it
was in Florida I don't know there was a
pride event on Fridays across the
country but they were canceled when kids
could not be there they're like ah kids
can't be here what are we doing this
what are we doing this for we can't have
sex with chokers on floats if there
isn't a six-year-old there they're
trying to put a pole in every Chuck E
cheese
there already is one Nick yeah there
already is
I've used it uh but I bring sanitizer so
it's okay Chuck E Cheese's not proud is
really crappy now by the way I went
there recently remember we were
literally at the robot I don't remember
because I've never been in one of those
dumps I don't have kids unless I'm
trying to pick them up why would I be in
there
I have a slice to me
their pizza's not bad uh it's a live
show by the way Monday through Friday
Monday their Pizza is not bad sucks shut
up how is it really okay it's not
terrible it's really not getting back
from Montreal but how is it really all
right well Montreal okay oh you got good
pizza up there I've had we do have good
Pizza Guys New York your New York and
Boston so no pizza is good to you
Montreal is good but now there are
restaurants releasing montreal-style
Pizza Mike there's no such thing it's
not a style we just have pizza it's just
so I don't understand we've got enough
rest it's a Monday show live uh Monday
through Friday weekday show Monday
through Friday 10 a.m Eastern uh so you
can just uh if you're watching right now
on Rumble right now you just click that
button once we go off Rumble you'll see
like that button right now you hit Mud
Club and guess what you get to continue
watching
foreign
[Music]
gay people love to be detained yes
generalization they'd love to be
restrained oh that's it yeah sorry yeah
uh and this was introduced by uh uh
what's his name uh obviously Cory Booker
uh pramila uh what's his name jayapod
yeah so yeah exactly the bill broadly
defines very broadly protects what they
would call vulnerable persons that means
under 21 over 60 pregnant women I'm
surprised I say women are not pregnant
persons uh mental physical disabilities
that makes sense and then also
lgbtqi Plus
so these are protected persons who will
not be detained at the border and
unsurprising of course are the new image
is now more emerging from the border uh
today what you see is I mean it's a
pandemic oh my gosh oh it happened now
we know who to turn away and the federal
government they've instituted an LGBT
because you're asking how how they get a
litmus test it's a tough chance it's
whether the migrants know all the words
to Tiny Dancer
they will also accept
uh for either Hamilton or Miss Saigon
knowing all the tracks to Cher's
greatest hits
lesbians qualify with proof of purchase
from Subaru Orvis or Play It Again
softball the point is it's a stupid rule
if you if you're mentally insane you
also fall into that category exactly so
so yes yes no no they said it they say
anybody with a mental illness were like
wow that's a protected person we must
Usher them right in to be a
schizophrenic in L.A yes because we
don't have enough of them
foreign
[Music]
exactly so don't why do we have to play
these games Schlitz it's his first
miracle
yeah it's a lesser Miracle it could have
gone with Steel Reserve so let's let's
think about this again are people
looking out for you your representatives
right they're supposed to be your
representatives that's where a
constitutional republic okay so not only
do we have open borders pretty much but
now we have really double super super
extra double secret borders if you're
lgbtq AI plus and again we're joking
about the fact that litmus test how do
you know you don't think you're going to
have some people you don't think El
Chapo is going to put on some lipstick
in a wig I know right we have you the
average American who is not part of the
0.5 percent of the population who has to
deal with the economy who has to deal
with skyrocketing crime in major cities
we have 50 million fentanyl
fentanyl-lace pills right that have just
made it across the border ten thousand
pounds of powdered fentanyl was seized
just last year border encounters have
gone up 257 since 2020. 60 of
unaccompanied minors are caught by
cartels are forced into child porn to
force into drug trafficking sex
trafficking but instead the government
decides what's most important is to make
sure that the backup dancers for lizzo's
drag show get the right-of-way I mean do
you at a certain point is it
conspiratorial to say this government
wants it to get so bad for you that you
react that's what that's what feels like
it definitely does and let's just be
clear I don't want to say the government
Cory Booker a clown that happens to be
masquerading as a senator right now is
one of the people pushing this and but
here's the thing it's so in line with
the message for the Democrats that I
would be surprised if it didn't pass
yeah like it's a joke to us but it's
like well we this is really stupid but I
guess I gotta I gotta sign off also by
the way if you put Cory Booker and AOC
together you get one good eye
which one yeah
I don't know
I haven't kept track and there's a
reverse Mirror Image when I watch it but
that's true it seems like the evils just
ends up shifting your corneas at some
point I don't know how it works you see
Satan's penis as well yes
good Lord
the bigger things to worry about at the
border uh you know as a matter of fact
we always have exclusive we have the
camera we take you exclusive to what's
going on at the border right now
[Music]
[Applause]
it's sad when they every time they get
separated it's a barbecue of George
Lopez's house
who I love by the way yeah plenty of
Maracas it's always fun when they do I
particularly like it when he makes jokes
about how white people are different
from Mexicans no but I like I honestly I
like because he hits white people where
they deserve to be hit like naming the
kid Cooper and like that seriously
I mean we have grown a little soft as a
race yeah we absolutely have but I'm a
Carlos Mencia guy yeah
I see me go right with you just agreeing
with the whole yeah
you do the cartoon double take
it's like he's a park ranger from Yogi
Bear
uh so anyways does that bring us to our
next story anymore comments on the
border this is what's happening at the
board this is actual matter of policy
and you have to ask yourself again not
what is it that happens within our
system what would happen if the left had
their way completely unfettered so we
have open borders and really open for
lgbtqaaip no actual commentary there no
no specifications as far as how you
gauge exactly what they are and now the
United States has decided remember how
Superman
it used to be uh was it a freedom
justice the American way yes yeah now
it's just Cox so
this weekend Tokyo held its annual gay
pride parade which no one cares about in
Japan and the media desperately wants to
make it a huge deal and then we'll enter
the U.S
[Music]
foreign
I'll I'll take the heat for this I'll
take these arrows is it just me or is it
a lot harder to tell who's gay or trans
there that's fair I can't tell if it's a
guy dressed up as a woman or a woman
they all look like they have uh you know
in their eyes
um
Pearl Harbor
[Laughter]
yeah no come on different flags what are
we doing to the we're exporting this all
over them they didn't do anything we say
the gym well this is the thing too so
Reuters posted that that video uh really
was a big deal and then they posted with
a caption cheering flag wagging crowds
gathered in Tokyo for the First full
pride parade in four years celebrating
advances in lgbtq rights but demanding
Japan join other Advanced Nations and
legally recognizing same-sex marriage
and here's the thing there are a few
fast facts that you need to know the
pride parade in Japan no one really
actually cares about it okay so in New
York for example the attendance was 5
million those are the people who are
left in that City who haven't been
killed and then in Tokyo it's ten
thousand ah ten thousand to give you an
idea of professional wrestling shows in
Japan will regularly fill the Superdome
uh with you know 90 something thousand
people I was about to say that the Tokyo
big city still right Big Ten Thousand
okay yeah that's a small number for such
a large city and and this is the thing
they don't care about I think a lot of
people lose they think that we've been
told the United States is the only
country that we're so right-wing no no
we're actually significantly further
left than a lot of other countries on
social issues if you look at our
abortion laws even compared to most of
Europe if you look at the lgbtq compared
to all of Asia and even actually a lot
of
true
[Music]
you have to create a we had to create a
law that you can't uh you can't strip in
front of a challenge oh no no no no you
mean a jail pervert
no a death penalty yeah death penalty no
no no no no no no no you don't sorry
cultural differences I don't know I
don't know so the Democrats here in the
United States are not only trying to
force Progressive value I don't want to
say progressive they're trying to force
other countries right this is part of
the leverage that we use so an example
the U.S ambassador to Tokyo Rahm Emanuel
most known for poking on people's uh is
that right yeah he's no idea you ever
you ever doubted the swamp what you ever
doubted to swamp Rahm Emanuel is an
ambassador to Tokyo exactly how's he
qualified has this guy ever held private
office in his adult life yeah he came up
with a crisis right yeah exactly never
let a good crisis go so yeah that's who
you want handling never let a chest in
the shower go unpoked remember that
exactly you're going to do what I say
it's like this is the problem these guys
have never been punched in the mouth I
know somebody's bit his finger off yeah
well you would hope but that's a sign of
pride in Japan like oh Yakuza he's like
no it was a queer in the shower
in the shower so that's the name of my
Memoir yes
name of my high school band yeah
I thought it was like reverse psychology
to pick up chicks never worked so he
celebrated this event on Twitter rum
Emanuel saying now is the time now is
the moment for Japan to be all that
Japan couldn't be today was a parade
with purpose ten thousand people just to
be clear very very small single digit
percentage compared to the United States
of America with a city of 39.1 million
yeah a little density
crying out loud like geez you could only
muster ten thousand five thousand ten
thousand people it's 39 million 39
minutes probably the greater Tokyo area
like right around there I don't know for
sure that seems like yeah a lot of
people that's what they refer to as the
Tokyo Metroplex that's the Tokyo Metro
they have tiny dicks now we're gonna cut
their balls off come on oh come on Nick
oh shut up it's early
well it's a lot easier to be an Alissa
concert that's the thing it's just you
can't really tell uh here 's the thing
the Japanese responded the Japanese
responded and they said Japan isn't
America they said Japan is not matter
Japanese are not here to be controlled
by Biden Administration Stoppers this
activist is what someone tweeted out
how do you know how to do that
activists how do you know how to do this
no it's a wasted childhood
and then another tweet was this is Way
Beyond what we can tolerate now here's
the thing I don't know if you're history
Buffs Japan once they get pushed too far
they start pulling some they start
pulling some crap so I don't really know
if we want to be put if we want to be
poking this what are they going to do
stop the flow of Chopsticks
again they're gonna sorry that's China
That's Japanese too right yes Japanese
wait I go to sushi places they have
chops yeah they also have yeah they eat
live frogs too well I don't have a
problem with that I love French girls
so are you Chinese or Japanese
I don't think that someone is referred
to French people as frogs and the better
half of 40 years I don't give a I
just did I'm bringing hate back
he's the 10
you guys are so Progressive with your
stop with your horseshit by the
way smash the like button if you're
watching on YouTube it helps with the
algorithm but why are you watching on
YouTube head on over to rumble where
none of this matters because you know
there's a YouTube Dub button which we
always have to use no thank goodness God
only knows how uh the strikes uh take
place on YouTube but this is something
that I think all of us can agree like
we're proud to be American I've always
been proud to be American but again that
is changing a little bit because we no
longer
I guess sort of I should say the focal
point is no longer what's made America
America there's far more focus on
lgbtqaip there's far more focus on
equity on brow beating ourselves in a
public Arena than there is on actually
being proud of our country and what made
our country great we should be exporting
values like democracy or you know
representative constitutional republics
which be exporting values like human
rights which the military may or may not
have done effectively
but you can't even argue that that's the
attempt at this point so to give you an
idea I think we have some clips here the
United States like Democrats they're
trying to now rebuild the rest of the
world uh in their own image to
reinvigorate our leadership on the
lgbtqi issues and do it internationally
you know we'll ensure diplomacy and
foreign assistance are working to
promote the rights of those individuals
included by combating criminalization
and protecting the lgbtq refugees and
Asylum Seekers
Jesus this is our priority Focus think
about this this is what when people will
say you're too far that you know too far
to the uh the right Liberty and you're a
non-interventionist okay
[Music]
foreign
people say this 10 people in a room
deciding this yeah no you're absolutely
eight of them are gay yes one of them's
David Geffen I don't know who the other
guys
Jerry natal is another one sitting on
his lap
um yeah it's it's a it's so specific to
die on this hill I don't understand why
but it's to take it really is not just
it's to bring us to our needs in this
country first and and then I I it's a
constant assault on the family here it's
like if you do this and say men and
women don't exist there's no more family
and now government becomes the head of
it yeah and that's called Marxism last
time I checked I mean the nuclear
family's the enemy yep right you're
absolutely right so what's the big
mystery let's just as a matter
of fact there's actually I mean look at
Russia's Theory no if you look at
Marxist theory it's there are no
parental rights the idea of parental
rights is fascist right and that's a big
part here there are no parental rights
there's communal rights it takes a
village right that's why your children
are being targeted and now they're at
the first step so in the country right
now it's to involve children in places
like Japan where they clearly won't do
that or places abroad it's now they're
going through the earlier phase of the
rainbow flag and then it'll be the gay
marriage and then and then it'll go down
and down that slippery slope the slope's
covered in Astroglide to and kids need
to be able to transition or you'll take
the children away from their parents
which is what we're seeing in places
like Washington state did you ever
thought did you
from their parents if they don't put
them on puberty blockers or perform a
sex change at six seven eight years old
yeah and I don't think it was by
accident that they were carrying Mickey
Mouse gay pride there you go placards in
that video that we saw at the very
beginning but look you joked around
about this or Nick did I prefer them
when they were bombing us people said
well oh we cut off their oil supply and
so they felt threatened right this is
far worse than that
will destroy their families yeah if
we're exporting something that will
destroy their culture right that is far
far you know what else they have a
Birthright problem yeah so let's just do
this let's do this for people chemically
sterilize themselves and then let's tell
them all the rest of them to be gay it's
like well yes there you go population
bomb you're done the country that has
used panty vending machines thinks that
were weird
[Laughter]
and the right yeah
and by the way this is reflected here
you think that we're stronger this
doesn't work here in the United States
because the people who wanted to spread
tree truth Freedom the American way are
military people who joined up I'm not
saying people at the Pentagon all share
these values but certainly a lot of
people joining the forces right joining
the military well we've been having a
recruiting shortage for a very long time
just in 2022 they fell short by fifteen
thousand geez okay this is a consistent
pattern why they want police forces they
want the military to be Progressive woke
petri dishes at this point didn't happen
by accident remember when it used to be
the Army be all you can be even in the
Army National Guard those guys for
crying out loud used to wear flippers
and drink spritzers they're considered
tough if you look at today's standards
this was the actual recruiting ad turns
out doesn't appeal to the people who you
want joining the military who basically
are looking for a legal right to murder
this is the recruitment act it begins in
California
but the little girl raised by two moms
[Music]
although I had a fairly typical
childhood took ballet played violin I
also marched for equality
I like to think I've been defending
freedom for that Mom just crossed the
Rio Grande
and after meeting with an army recruiter
I found it
a way to prove my
[Music]
mind all right
how about proving your outer strength
let's start with Pull-Ups
no no we changed that yeah that's right
you can do a dead hang now which is how
they find half of them in the barracks
well 41 if I could go back a little did
he say panty vending machines he did yes
in Japan edible really yeah and they
think we're weird
I don't see a problem with that I don't
sell much either but the point is get
used to
you never know what you're gonna need
one
you can get a clock bar and a nice
Tiffany oh my God that's I don't know if
they sell Clarks in Japan it's clock
it's a crock pot
oh my God a dirty panty is it are they
good no I don't know no they used to be
I think they got rid of them because it
was rounded it's like carvana with a
because
you pull the thing lizzo pants break the
machine
like to another big claw they use
sometimes yeah
oh good yeah yeah there you go it's so
weird I don't think they were I was over
there I didn't see those no they don't
exist anymore I don't think that they
were actually used because it seems like
it would be too easy to frame someone
for murder well you just have DNA yeah I
mean that's why I have a DNA Scraper on
my pen if you guys are always wondering
why I stab you guys aren't you surprised
that we have like the LGBT community
hasn't thought of that well I'm sure
they probably have I'm sure they have
them like in their truck stops want to
get AIDS
no there is no age anymore there's a
breath pill what's those monkey pox AIDS
is last uh AIDS is last season D6
Liberace
when you hit it it's just the piano
being used as a typewriter ding
for Liberace incredibly talented just
super gay but none of we weren't the one
we were none the wiser no clue but Merv
Griffin was straight at that point
uh by the way do you remember this this
is something I'm constantly reminded of
because Republicans conservatives were
really upset I I still would be
but I feel this way in Reverse you heard
me kind of touch on it earlier but for
those of you who are kind of new younger
viewers you may not remember Michelle
Obama saying this after her uh
her wife became president
let me tell you something for the first
time in my adult lifetime I'm really
proud of my country and not just because
Barack has done well but because I think
people are hungry for change
and I'm at this phase I mean we can help
don't you feel a little bit embarrassed
sometimes to be American now on the
international stage
wasn't just me running stuff like that
no absolutely like because of the way
that we have changed our values and if
that was in 2016 yeah your husband was
President for eight years you're finally
to the point yeah he took eight years to
make you proud of your country you sure
this country didn't do anything else to
make you proud I don't know like in
slavery in the entire world as much as
we possibly could well you're splitting
Champion women's rights in the rest of
the world I don't know develop an
economic system that has been the light
of the rest of the world the only reason
that fascism and communism and Marxism
didn't take over the world maybe there's
a few things that we've done that's
great mistakes yeah you're splitting
nappy hairs now Gerald
in your adult life Michelle do you want
to be a victim your whole life you're
the first lady what do you think Nick do
you feel that am I the only one do you
feel that way sometimes where you see
what's going on what we transport and
you go you know I'm kind of ashamed of
at least a portion of what this country
has become yeah especially with the
military uh aspect which is more on the
international yeah scene and people see
I don't know what I was watching but
they put up the recruitment of it was an
ad for the Russia's yeah the Russian
military in the United States right yeah
compared to yeah I uh I feel a little
and like I said flying the rainbow fly I
don't under I don't somebody has to
explain to me why that's the thing where
use the cudgel we're using or why the
far left is using us to get where they
want to go I guess it's part of these
separate it's it's yeah that's the
family but it's also clever because
thing a lot of people don't realize what
is America's and I mean this not as far
as our our Commodities what's our
biggest export sometimes people think
oil yeah no it's culture it's culture
yeah for sure it's culture films you
look at television shows I grew up in
Canada where people used to about
the United States right because I had an
inferiority complex and they would go
home use their electricity use their
microwave turn on their light bulb maybe
watch their television set like Seinfeld
or The Simpsons then about America
but now the left understands and Andrew
Breitbart talked about this how
everything else is actually is upstream
or Downstream I always forget which way
is appropriate from culture and now the
left says we're going to we are going to
export a culture uh exclusively in our
image because it's really hard to be
this far off the beam when you're the
world superpower if everyone else isn't
on board and you know what we're
disconnected with the rest of the world
they think we've lost our marbles at
this point we've gone so far left on the
social issues we have nothing in common
with any of Asia let alone Japan with a
good portion of Europe think about that
there's a huge divide taking place and
we're on the wrong side of that
historically that's the first time that
I can say that my adult life we are on
the wrong side of history on this one
well and it weakens us yeah on the
international stage right now so it's
not just about military might it's about
the culture that we're exporting if the
world at some point says we hate these
guys they're strong military that's fine
right there's not a whole lot they can
do about it but if it's like they're
destroying our culture yeah now we have
to fight now we have to push back now we
have to form other alliances because we
don't have a choice we're in a corner
now right but it's striking us it's
strengthening us on a Broadway stage yes
it is that's important I think
Off-Broadway but the point remains yes
awesome yeah yes 86 yes exactly we have
to be self-important Pricks that's how
you know you don't want to talk with
someone at a dinner party I want to go
see this Off-Broadway play you're like
this is going to be very interesting
okay bye someone in a turtleneck I am
born all right there we go please I want
to watch the rendition of boys in the
hood on the stage but not this
um Iceman Cometh yes sir and Larry
Storch
button
I just coughed up along okay this also
brings us to speaking of uh cultural
exports that we hate and that are
laughable AOC oh yeah the
but a waste of tits
I know I want to despise Oliver as much
but let's be honest so when people say
like oh she's ugly guys come on you lose
your leg to stand now No One Believes
you
um she believes that the government now
and this is a call to action and again
we'll kind of make the case here so you
understand just the the size of the
barrel of the gun that you are staring
down right now they want to export a
specific set of cultural values they
want to import specific people right a
specific set of cultural values and they
want to eliminate your cultural values
from the public pool of information in
discourse case in point AOC is now
aggressively demanded the government
regulate what you see on air and of
course she strawman's the argument but
let's start
I believe that when it comes to
broadcast television like Fox News these
are subject to
to federal law Federal Regulation in
terms of what's allowed on air and what
isn't okay she specifically complains
about Tucker and singles him out and
then I have a question a genuine anyone
in here can answer but I don't think
you're going to be able to let's see the
clip with her talking about Tucker when
you look at what Tucker Carlson and some
of these other folks on Fox do it is
very very clearly incitement of violence
very clearly incitement of violence and
that is the line that I think we have to
be willing to contend with okay here's a
question for you I want you guys to come
anyone if you're watching right now
comment below
can you name me one
one specific incitement to violence from
Tucker Carlson from this show
one can anyone think of one and I'm
trying to be fair here one do they do
you mean when they say I think
[Music]
that's not a trick I can't think of
anything no no and I watch them a lot I
can't think of one and here's something
that you notice with the Left Right the
accusation the crime is very broad right
it's very broad it's there's this
incitement to violence okay what
specifically but the CR the punishment
for the crime is specific regulation and
removing of hate speech online right
it's total removal the accusation the
crime is so broad that it can't be
proven the punishment is specific that
it hurts that's not how our legal system
works and this is the problem with the
court of public opinion if someone
commits a crime for example you could
you burn down a Walgreens I think that
you should be charged with arson you
steal something from a CVS I don't care
if it's 952 dollars it's below the
threshold you should be charged with
theft specific crime specific punishment
they always have these very broad
assertions of the act of violence or
crime with very specific damaging
punishments yeah you noticed that Trend
and she said clearly clearly and it's
like whoa whoa hold on what you need to
say is legally but you can't right
legally that was incitement to violence
okay we can all get on board of that but
yeah there's a definition for that and
there's a process to prove it and I'll
get to very specific examples of calls
to violence from the left which I
believe they should be punished for so
here's the thing the solution is
censorship of all platforms and by the
way she was talking with Gen sackey
again we're talking about the swamp
she's now a host pasaki
you don't stare yeah I don't look it's
silent that there is no silent P if the
p is there I'm pronouncing it I'm sorry
well maybe you and your privileged
American sorry
good I'm glad we settled it so Jen
sackey she was working in the
administration then she gets a job just
like Stephanopoulos right you look at
all these people this is we're talking
about the swamp you're not just talking
about elected officials you're talking
about unelected people in office like uh
fauci you're talking about lobbyists but
you're also talking about the
entertainment media uh and political
industrial complex it is so incestuous
jensaki is qualified to be a host and I
know you see it on the right sometimes
too but these people on the left never
we just talked about Rahm Emanuel he's
an ambassador to Japan so this is the
host with uh with AOC but if you don't
remember gen saki specifically called
this was after Joe Rogan by the way Joe
Rogan defended himself saying Ivermectin
is not just horse dewormer that's not
accurate that's not fair and the White
House Press Secretary now a host who's
hosting AOC nothing wrong there called
for censorship referring to it as
Spotify because she's an idiot but in
case you've forgotten disclaimer it's a
positive step but we want every platform
to continue doing more to call out
missing and missing disinformation while
also uplifting accurate information our
hope is that all major Tech platforms
and all major news sources for that
matter be responsible and be vigilant to
ensure the American people have access
to accurate information on something as
significant as covid-19 yep and by the
way in case you've forgotten the
accurate information was Banning anyone
who said that it could have leaked from
a lab ah as opposed to a Wuhan Market
when did Conan start transition
I always thought it was weird when she
came out she did the dance
how could imagine AOC having the balls
wasn't our vice president Harris bailing
people out during the riots yeah talking
about inciting violence are you
me which by the way is a complete about
face because she when she was working in
California she wanted to keep inmates in
prison longer to act as a slave labor
for the government beyond their sentence
he has a real moral compass yeah and
look she knew at the time that every
single one of the tech companies was
going to do her bidding compare that to
Elon Musk taking over Twitter and now
trolling his detractors by giving them a
blue check mark that is only available
for purchase right so much so they have
to come out and go no I didn't pay the
eight dollars exactly it's reverse
virtue signaling I know it's fantastic
zillionaires it's like the mark of the
anti-beast yeah he's like here's your
blue check mark no no I didn't pay for
it oh I swear I'm complicit with the
government and you're right they you
know they go right to MSNBC after they
work they use Congress like as uh
foreign
[Music]
for example fight like hell remember
Donald Trump said make your voices heard
peacefully patriotically but he said
you're gonna have to fight like hell
they said that's a call to violence
this is the problem with a broad
criminal description with very specific
penalties let's go to AOC should she be
censored for when there were violent
protests across this country calling for
more but more importantly clapping like
she's a cast member and I am Sam
[Applause]
[Music]
come on
can you show that again that's not
that's not the key Point here but that's
not the way a normal person claps can
you show us that again yeah all right oh
that's why a formal bartender Club
make me a margarita you come on
he's afraid she's gonna
he's gonna be illegitimate
so are you kids and by the way here are
the uh oh come on I'm sure she's parents
she doesn't have any kids I'm not
talking about her all the jerk offs
behind her
[Laughter]
too let's go
Civics okay has the left called for
violence again can we provide specific
examples well you know what just I'm
glad you asked
uh how cold is it yeah exactly I'm glad
you asked out there when that was my
kids when they talked to blippi the
clown who I'd like to crucify
um literally yes yes quite literally
would like to crucify it's a license to
print money children's programming on
YouTube and it just makes me angry but
so I interact as though you can hear me
uh let's start with calls to violence
well we'll go through media
personalities and then politicians and
then celebrities so let's just start
with media personalities like sacky
though I know she's kind of a hybrid
demonic figure our country was started
because this is how the Boston Tea Party
rioting
so don't do not get it twisted and think
that oh this is some something that has
not never happened before and then this
is so terrible and where are we and
these Savages
I wish the Democrats would play that
game to 10 of the levels that the
Republicans do until the Democrats stop
rolling over for this and saying well
we're not going to dirty our hands when
they go high we go low so when they go
low we get baseball bats that should be
the next you know big ones get Obama out
there saying when they go low we get
baseball bats I think that would solve
this completely but today threatens our
national security these things have deep
ugly Roots inextricably tied to slavery
and it's aftermath and we'd be better
off just unearthing it and airing it out
if we really want repair
I like the way it is yeah by the way to
be fair though uh back to lemon's
comment uh who can forget the famous
revolutionary Mantra give me free
from Walgreens or give me death so he
wasn't all awesome that's 100 true yeah
that's just like the Boston Tea Party
really you think the founding fathers
would have stood for this think about
what the Boston Tea Party was they
dumped one of the most valuable
Commodities in the world into the harbor
as a screw you because you wanted to put
a tax on their breakfast beverage and
this was pre-energy drink yes
and they didn't just
people people's lives were being
destroyed at the moment that Don Lemon
is chuckling about don't act don't get
it twisted like this has never happened
before yes protests and riots have
happened we've had them in Detroit we've
had them in LA with Watts we've had tons
of riots around the country where people
have been killed and lives have been
roomed yes Don is that good right
especially when it's based on what he
was talking about at the time which was
George Floyd right yeah good that you
guys drummed that up and made that into
a fever pitch so that we had the Summer
of Love during covid but I guess coven
paused during that time it paused yeah I
did it pause because it could only it
can't jump from Criminal to criminal
well there's a natural immunity shouting
in the streets it it can't survive no
you can't there's a natural immunity
when you're a Serial felon something
about runs away from no cash bail
science I don't know I'm not a molecular
biologist so you have the media
figureheads but then you also have
politicians
but if you see anybody from that cabinet
in a restaurant James
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Brown's face
everyone beware because they're not
gonna stop it is gonna they're not gonna
stop before election day in November and
they're not gonna look at idiot on the
left and that should be everyone should
take note of that she said they're not
going to stop Nordstrom I want to tell
you Gore such I want to tell you
Kavanaugh
release the Whirlwind and you will pay
the price he misspoke him but he just
released wind says the guy wearing
Jeanine Garofalo Rim glasses
but that's how you know he's he's
important exactly yeah he watches off
off Broadway Amy schum is funny yes I
love it though I particularly love it
when uh Maxine Waters starts walking
away and they put the cape on her yes
I thought she was done she's not done
oh lean I ran out of gasoline that's
very old school
yes I forgot that she was James Brown so
again this is kind of the double
standard that we're seeing and this is
why this is so it's more important than
Texas so we'll get to fiscal policy with
the Gerald nose stuff in a little bit
when culture changes right we've talked
about what they're importing what
they're trying to export and they want
to eliminate this is like Nick said
there's a few people a little more than
10 people determining this in a room who
do you think decides how do you think
that someone like Alex Jones gets
removed from Facebook Instagram YouTube
Spotify Apple Twitter in the same day
how do you how do you think it happens
that all of a sudden
it's released as far as the warning on
YouTube on Facebook on Instagram the
same day where okay now you can say it
may be leaked in a lab they want to
accuse you of violence when disagreeing
with them it's very broad with the
punishment that's very specific but
here's the thing it's not punishing me
it's not punishing people like Nick who
have their own shows it's punishing you
it's preventing you from hearing that
information and you know what that does
that leads to actual violence if you
want a Civil War what you do is you
silence half the country you other them
you make sure that the rest of the
country never actually hears their own
point of view you never engage in an
actual conversation and then you say I
don't know how we came to this boiling
point it's a very very dangerous uh time
in history when you think of where we
are and what it is that they're
specifically doing yeah well and
especially when you say that the other
side is calling for violence and you
completely ignore the times when you're
actually
either calling for violence I think what
frustrated us about that moment was
that's when we needed politicians to
Tamp this down we needed people because
a lot of those comments were in the late
spring early summer when these things
were really just getting going and
really starting to be a problem and I
was having conversations with my wife
about make sure you have a gun we have
kids in the car if you end up in a
situation where there's a protest how do
you defend yourself do you eat the gas
do you like all of us were looking for
politicians to be the adults in the room
and to say whoa whoa whoa I understand
we're on it these guys will face trial
Justice will be served and all they did
is say they're going to be in the
streets don't expect them to leave the
streets they shouldn't leave the streets
and by the way we've done this kind of
stuff before this is what this country
is founded on don't get it twisted right
thanks for the help guys so what happens
is when they're violent there's no call
to end right violent voice and now once
that's gone away for a little bit
because you know they won an election
they go okay now let's eliminate
eliminate voices of disagreement let's
paint them it's really hard it's really
hard to label people in this room
violent when the riots are going on so
that rhetoric goes away a little bit
they say you know stop Asian hate stop
Jewish whatever it is they try and paint
you as fascists and then once they're no
longer being violent at the current
moment in time they accuse you of just
don't don't be disrupted by their
patterns it really is easy to predict
well and by the way so you know how I
know they're lying January 6th their
lips are moving oh the minute that it
came to their doorstep oh no please
don't tell them to to protest yeah don't
tell them to come knock on our door
because it could get violent do people
forget that they burned down a church
like a month before that remember they
burned down the church and they were
trying to kick in the barricade at the
White House Rand Paul barely got out of
there and almost got assaulted on the
way out like this this came to their
door and they said oh my gosh we have to
be careful somebody please say something
to calm the crowd yeah the minute that
it wasn't on their doorstep they were
like oh say whatever you want guys this
is just part of how democracy was yeah
they mocked Donald Trump as bunker boy
because he didn't want to be shot the
people the people uh in government and
the people of media that say this type
of insightful crap on the left they
they're they're they don't have to
experience the consequences of their
policies they're living in gated
communities and uh you know it's the old
story of Eureka history no of course
this is the problem California's
appropriate prototype for that right and
New York City in New York City New York
City Chuck Schumer do you think he's the
one having a side step uh piles of human
feces no he doesn't have Bobby's
boyfriends yeah he doesn't have to worry
about getting a gun permit is his
security house of course he does fine I
don't need a gun I've got seven guys
around me who do so it's about punishing
law-abiding citizens it's about turning
law-abiding citizens into criminals and
turning criminals into a voting base
it's about punishing uh you for being
responsible this is the problem when we
talk about Equity the only way to
enforce Equity through the government
right not equality Equity is to punish
those who have lived their lives
responsibly and that's why the American
dream is dying because this brings us to
another story if you have good credit
you want to buy a house well right now
you're screwed that brings us to an
edition of Gerald knows things
Spirit new expense hate all of you
a new federal housing Rule and by the
way we talked about how the student loan
forgiveness is one of the greatest
wealth transfers to fun enough wealthy
Americans young wealthy white uh
in American history uh right now there's
a new federal housing rule that will
redistribute wealth but what we'll do
it'll punish you if you have lived your
life in a disciplined way if you're a
home buyer with good credit you're now
going to have to pay higher mortgages to
subsidize high-risk borrowers it's
almost like we've lived this before but
I don't know here's a clip
I get the idea of the campaign promise
to get the rich to pay their fair share
uh but aren't there going to be a lot of
folks in the middle class who have just
been responsible and have good credit
who are going to also be caught up in
this
yeah it's like a penalty for good credit
and putting a high down payment I'm
refinancing two of my properties no
offense but uh you know if I do it
before August and I won't get hit with
that timing my problem with the forty
dollars isn't the amount it is whether
this is the best way to redistribute
wealth and close the housing Gap in
America so let me set this up and then
Gerald of course knows things so um the
rule will require buyers with
630 or more credit scores to pay forty
dollars more per month on a four hundred
thousand dollar loan in order to
subsidize people who have a lower score
Yeah so basically you're going to have
to pay higher fees yeah happiest by the
way most happy about these new
regulations is this guy he is having a
great time whoa well yeah
important and people so one of the
things when you buy a house right so
your credit score matters and they set
the line at 630 630. I'm just saying
from a from a financial perspective when
they look at a 630 that's not exactly
great this is right this is a tax on the
middle class guys like you have no idea
this is not ultra wealthy people paying
for people who are dirt dirt poor and
cannot afford anything that's not what's
good what's even worse buyers who put
down 20 or more are the ones who are
going to face the highest fees to be
clear so in other words what used to be
a requirement is now going to be a
punishment wait hold on a second you
saved the money wait a second you don't
have debt wait a second you have a
better credit score wait a second you
didn't buy a car that you couldn't
afford now you have to pay for the other
person who did yeah you're about to come
in here we have an admonishment to deal
out it's actually
680.80
admonished it's I always make that
mistake with the three in the eight yeah
okay so 680's best oh 18 oh it looked
like a three it's an eight I thought I
thought it was Chris Hanson yes it's a
three so 680 is definitely better but
it's still like when you're when you're
talking about credit scores that's still
going to be a lot of Working Class
People it's still it's punishing someone
with a good credit score what's the
reason to get it and I know people say
you think people won't get a good credit
score because they're going to uh
they're gonna have to pay 40 no I think
people won't get a good credit score if
yes they have to pay 40 if they actually
have to pay back their loans if they're
above the threshold for rent forgiveness
if they don't get some kind of covet
stipend if they don't qualify for
welfare benefits at a certain point you
go my life would be easier if I did
absolutely nothing and collected these
checks it would certainly be more
comfortable I do think at a certain
point you go hold on a second I didn't
take out a student loan which is being
forgiven for that guy I went to a trade
now I'm being taxed for I'm being
punished if I want to buy a house I did
everything right and I'm being punished
when I know that my brother who's the
Dropout deadbeat is going to
receive every single government benefit
at a certain point yes not just this but
in totality yes people will stop trying
right and by the way it was forty
dollars per per month right yes 30 years
that you will be paying this if you take
the average time unless you refinance
and then of course it could just be the
rest of your life that you're paying all
of this money and by the way that 400
000 you're like oh well that's a lot of
home not in California not in New York
not in Connecticut not in these other
places it's not a lot of home and so if
you pay for a home that's five six seven
eight hundred thousand it's more money
Nick had a point about this certain run
through it yeah yeah what's next if uh
you have a perfect uh driving record you
know we're gonna slap a seven percent
tax on us so you know the people that
are carjacking us yes can get their own
car without having to shoot us in the
head they're going to jack you with an
Amex Platinum get out the car yeah
how did you qualify it's a new low
forgiveness they could do this all day
to us a day so much for White
Privilege you're an Italian Irishman
from the from Boston actually even a
tiny bit more Irish really I found that
out recently when you have and and look
I know Nick gets uncomfortable with
compliments but you have always been
known own because a lot of comedians
blow their money with having been
responsible with money were you raised
that way was that something that was
instilled in you when you were young uh
yes uh yeah I had an accountant when I
was in eighth grade did you I did a lot
of vowels in his last name I grew up
with Henry Block's kid Jack block no
yeah my dad look my dad we had five kids
he never made more than thirty eight
thousand dollars you know what I mean
yeah uh so yes we we learned response we
learned how to try and save how to be
responsible yeah and now there's no
reason to do that in a lot of ways what
are you gonna so think about it you live
off the government you live off the
government for a while you get rent
forgiveness this is when people say what
about people who can't pay their rent
let me ask you this was there
forgiveness
for the the people who were providing
homes and I'm not by the way I'm not
just talking about people who run giant
condos and Vanguard and BlackRock what
about the people who own five or six
properties right and they rent it out
was there forgiveness for them on their
mortgage was there forgiveness for them
on their payments in other words
forgiveness for the people who had no
interest in paying their rent what
happens here what happens here if people
can't make the payments in the house
it's not just about the 40 it's about
encouraging and leveraging and
pressuring Banks and Society at large to
provide loans to people who will not be
able to pay them back that's never hurt
us in the past that's never hurt us
something about Barney Frank's basement
20 on a house this is eighty thousand
dollars is what people will have to save
and with this economy with Joe Biden's
economy with inflation all the extra
stuff they're having to pay every single
month for the normal household goods to
live foods and services that adds up and
by the way it's 14 400 bucks over the
life of that loan but that's not the
real cost that's just the dollars you
spend if you've taken that 40 bucks and
paid it towards principal every single
month because of how they calculate
interest and do it for so long I
guarantee you it would probably be
closer to twenty eight thousand dollars
that that's an estimate because we don't
have an estimate because I'm doing the
math on the top of my head but just
paying down your mortgage but look I
understand that this all sounds really
really bad and if it sounds stupid to
you you just have to remember that
credit scores are actually racist but
leaving rent payments out of the formula
isn't just stupid it's racist because
while rent payments don't count toward
your credit score mortgage payments do
and guess who's more likely to have
mortgages white people oh no to be
polite I'll just call them McLemore fans
oh you funny so white people never
ran into a seller did you no I don't
even know she is a dead
nice hairdo well it's nice what the does
any wow
I know sometimes it's like an overload
there's so much wrong with it you can't
even pick oh the race the gender I mean
the humor it's you know who's more
likely to have mortgages white people
well awesome that makes you racist yeah
thank you thank you very much no it's a
statistic but you said statistics are
racist I don't understand the rules
sorry this is even being selective right
so you're telling me that white people
with great credit scores are going to
have to play for a pay for minorities
who have bad credit scores and it's like
but actually we don't actually have the
highest credit scores no we do not here
come the Asians to our rescue yet again
yes they actually have a set of 45
whereas whites have 734 but then you
have Hispanics at 701 higher than
I didn't mean in a bad way I just you
know Tim laughed about it earlier when I
said it well they're not known for time
Hispanics are hard working but they're
not always known for timeliness because
I thought there'd be a few more late
pages first of the month you know of
course the Chinese have better credit
scores because their their parents and
grandparents from the old country you
know the whole credit card thing was
going on yeah before they got here
absolutely in a certain way and if you
don't if they shake your piggy bank and
it sounds empty the gym piano keys into
your neck so and by the way and the
average black credit score is 677 that
number is important because all they
have to do is accidentally pay their
credit card on time for about I don't
know four months and they're all of a
sudden in that category of 680 or or why
would they do that now because they'd be
punished the key is to keep it just
below 680. yes so like good enough that
you can get some favorable rates
probably not the best but like you can
still do the carvana thing but not so
high that Uncle Sam is any of the wiser
the best credit score is like that 670
range if you can do it right so look
there there's a handful of other uh
claims here that I want to get to all
right let's go through
he's not he's not doing it okay finally
thank you very much so subsidizing these
loans will make it easier for minorities
to buy homes right we just talked about
that a little bit but according to the
federal Housing Finance Agency director
Sandra Thompson the rule will increase
pricing support for purchasers borrowing
limited I'm sorry purchase borrowers
limited by income or by wealth right in
September 2022 Bank of America launched
a similar initiative they should just
title it give it give money away to
people who will never give it back yes
yes this is that predatory lending
remember that when you say predatory
lending as a kid yeah do this predatory
lending okay so Banks lend money yes
okay how do they make they make their
money when people pay it back and they
pay interest okay so explain to me
predatory lending predatory lending is
where these these Predators they lend to
people who could never pay it back okay
okay I think I'm missing something
because they make their money the bank
right yes when people pay it back and
there's interest so their their
predators who is it that they're they're
specific seeking out people who can't
pay it back okay hold on let's explain
this to me one more time
so the predatory lenders are giving away
money basically for free oh no sorry I
forgot the government ensures it oh no
no but I also I think I can it's
predatory when a bank does it it's
helpful when the government does it yes
and when the government shakes down the
bank and forces them to do it well
that's assumed in the process right so
look their program Bank of America I
gotta I gotta think like the executives
at Bank of America were like we got in
trouble for doing this on our own and
now they're telling us to do it again
right this is fantastic the program gave
first-time minority home buyers zero
down payments and zero closing cost
mortgages
all right hold on just as an aside do
you know what's important to have a down
payment so that you have skin in the
game yes so preferably with a higher
melanin concentration yes
I love it
just walk away from it
that's why you do it and penalize people
for doing that and that's why people
look for 20 yeah just going right over
that because I missed it I'm really
sorry I'm trying to think that wasn't
Jay Lewis was it I love it was this I
don't know who I was doing okay Jackie
Gleason baby something from there I
don't know do you know this goes back to
Clinton the CRA Community
all right well look here's the truth the
idea that crashed the markets in 2008
was exactly this loans were given to
buyers incapable of paying them back we
talked about that here's a quote from
Investopedia the subprime Meltdown was
the sharp increase in high-risk
mortgages that went into default
beginning in 2007 contributing to the
most severe worldwide I'll add that to
the quote recession in decades it wasn't
in there that was absolutely true and
look for all its faults The Big Short
did illustrate this pretty well no one
on the poll has good credit and they're
all cash Rich that's fair I think I read
Warren Buffett say something like that
no
right who's Warren Buffett it was a
great film except they didn't really
include the government complicity as
much as they should have none of this
makes sense look none of this works if
the government doesn't guarantee the
loans if the government doesn't
guarantee that they'll pay it to the
banks if the banks had to sink no
company is too big to fail just to be
clear you cannot have too big to fail
think of every industry that you hate
okay think of banking a big fan of
banking think of of Airlines think of
the automobile industry think of Ensure
health insurance companies these are
companies by the way where every at some
point or another a company or several
companies have been deemed too big to
fail have Airlines gotten better or have
they gotten more expensive and shittier
and CEOs walk off with bigger bonuses
you're mad at that why wouldn't they
when the fact is they can never go
bankrupt Banks they lend to people who
can't pay it back they can never go
bankrupt they're too big to fail
BlackRock Vanguard and a socialist
herself Elizabeth Warren said they need
to be deemed too big to fail so that
that way we can have our claws in and we
can regulate them and hopefully you know
at that point of course rebuild the
world our image with these ESG scores
too big to fail only screws you in the
country if the government is what deems
too big to fail that's the none of this
makes sense if you just say well hold on
a second we're not going to lend you
money why because you're not going to
pay it back and we're in the business of
being paid back and you're not going to
pay it we're not going to make any money
but then when the government says you
better give them that loan
or we're going to punish you and by the
way if they can't pay it back we'll give
you money there is no free market it's
not free enterprise at this point that
was explained that's the first time I
ever understood the whole thing yeah
thank you that's very true I'm angry
sure that's pretty well look and I I
paid it they revealed their motives in
the very beginning this is a really bad
idea and you're like oh why in the world
would they do this he revealed his
motives the guy that they were
interviewing at first you know Mr
talking here basically said you know he
was a candidate for mayor in DC which
means you're you know far far far left
right if you're going to run for mayor
he said this is a bad way to
redistribute income make the rich pay
their fair share and close the housing
Gap those were the three things we have
to redistribute income by penalizing
people who are successful we think white
people have better credit scores and
therefore they're going to be successful
and Rich and so we're going to penalize
them white people now are paying
minorities essentially right so that's
part one close the housing Gap well
everybody deserves housing in this
country
not everybody deserves equal access to
amazing homes if you can't afford it
yeah I thought we'd tried that before it
didn't work out for not everyone
deserves Ben Carson's bathroom with
chandeliers that's why we have Airbnb
now yes
destroy somebody else's house but they
don't have public toilets in San
Francisco for crying out loud it cost a
million dollars that's the Taj Mahal of
toilets really yeah well George Michael
was ahead of his time he knew where to
pick up he was it's just it's it's it
reveals what they're trying to do and if
you guys think that Bankers are bad the
federal government trying to appease a
voting block will always do things that
are far worse than Bankers can even
contemplate who would think that the
same people who demand that the Japanese
Embassy fly the rainbow flag might not
have your best interests at heart as it
comes to Home Loans I mean I hate to
connect it all together but stop being a
crazy conspiracy theorist this has been
Gerald knows things so we kind of
stepped on him I'm sorry
guys I'm gay
they said it I couldn't respond I had no
idea I don't know what happened uh by
the way hey Nick depalo of course he is
uh 5 p.m 5 p.m Eastern you go to
nickdepaloshow.com and of course you can
go there you can also subscribe at mug
club and you can subscribe get a mug for
him or you can subscribe like the point
is you get all you get access to all
this Monday through Thursday yeah yeah
you sounded like you weren't sure
it's uh yeah it's Monday Thursday at
five right that's right yeah East
Eastern time oh yeah eastern time and if
you're watching right now look you can
comment below you can hit the like
button on YouTube if you're watching on
Rumble this is the first week where it's
not free mug Club month we appreciate
the support now that you know what it is
that you're missing we're about to do
another full hour of show we're going to
play uh Pokemon or racial slur which no
doubt we could never do on the YouTube
so if you're watching on Rumble right
right now you just go down there and
there's a button that says mug club and
you join boom click it and for 89 a year
you get this show you get Nick you get
the Friday show you get this wonderful
hand-ass mug and you get more series
that are coming down the pike we thank
Rumble so much we're going to continue
doing this YouTube of course um you can
um you can piss off right now
foreign